now here's something that we love to do
this is a pressure pack night for a lot
of you and the nominees is sitting in
the audience and people are wondering
what are they thinking now I have had
this gift since I first started hosting
the show that I can look in anyone's
eyes and I know exactly what they're
thinking so watch the screen I'll tell
you what's on their mind
hmm this better not go too late I have
six parent-teacher conferences in the
morning Billie Jelena I love the sound
of that
for 20 days and 20 nights the emperor
penguin will march to play so extreme
it's a bought snow of the life
Andy Dufresne was my friend see Billy
didn't tell me that kiss was being
filmed so I want to thank my agent I
want to thank my writer and director for
creating the role of a strong black
woman that wasn't played by Tyler Perry
ready camera two ready camera two take
Marty take Marty take me take me push
him push him push him come on push it
that's too close pushback no he looks
too serious no no no no back back come
back in come back in go back out back
out back out back out come back in come
back in all right take multi-technology
take no t take melting
ah
yeah if I had him I'd lick him if I had
him I'd lick him if I had him I lickin
if I had a my lickin and that's what
everybody is thinking thank you